fifty-one seconds of motherfucking logos
it said that the West was Irish this is
the legend of the ghost writer it's
what's for dinner also roll credits
whatever this is he out read the devil
himself
well that doesn't even sound possible
also that's pretty easy when the devil
doesn't run also The Devil's lone mode
of transportation is running apparently
the thing about legends is sometimes
they're true and sometimes they're not
any other gems of wisdom for me before
we get started
economist it's on everything you do in
life every choice you make as a
consequence and with that great powerful
responsibility comes creeping up okay
you do things that thinking you ain't
making the choice the choice is making
you whatever that means
Marlboro somehow agreed to this product
placement that place their product and
direct proximity to a man coughing the
death from their product there you go
kid because he can never find more
cigarettes at the carnival Johnny and
Roxanne's love is addictive trees
forever
my dad sending me live with my mom but I
figured when I turned 24 tomorrow I'll
officially be on my own
impregnate her already tomorrow noon
when we here
yeah no sense in just leaving right now
because that'll get fade enough time to
put some kind of stupid obstacle in our
way
moody hits the fuckin expositional
jackpot with this shot right here Oh
random pieces of paper in the trash
better give that probably important
document a look art enduring neatly
through this letter into the wastebasket
instead of just crumbling it up like any
sorry second smoker who doesn't give a
fuck about cancer would do though he
could be easy right in his way to bang
town with Roxanne tomorrow but he just
had to be curious about trash did me
alright you know for all the sixty year
olds in the audience who enjoyed easy
brighter Johnny Blaze discount Johnny
Storm just wanted to tell you how much I
enjoyed watching you ride a lot of clock
and well after closing and not in a
creepy manner at all perhaps you'd ride
for me
apparently Satan needs ghost riders for
speedy bounty hunting he had a horse
rider and now he's recruiting a
motorcycle rider but why not choose a
helicopter pilot why does the devil soul
collecting ability have the limitation
of earthly speed anyway
and why is he recruiting his future
rider roughly twenty years before he
actually needs him
the lightning outside cause a shadow
like this this is clearly an inside
light shadow but whatever devil devil is
devil what if I could help your dad
would you be willing to make it to you
name your price
sure strange dude I've never seen before
in my life at the traveling carnival
I'll follow you anywhere well today is
yes the creepy guy who showed up out of
nowhere and started talking about your
cancer dad is definitely quite the
jokester contract itself cuts
perspective signee causing a blood drop
which the devil counts as a signature
but which Johnny had zero control over
whatsoever so I'm calling bulletin on
the devil's bullshit contract bull also
dumb motherfucker who just signed his
soul to the devil wakes up like it's all
a dream cliche great write the docs
raise this morning this guy is not only
a hundred percent healed thanks to the
devil's contract but also woke up
determined to go get x rays after the
letter we saw proved he's been actively
avoiding contact with his doctor and he
got an appointment x-rays and a
diagnosis before Johnny even woke up oh
I sold my soul to the devil pace roll
mail we'll have the cops on you before
you get to county line no he won't for a
couple of reasons first we were told
that she was being sent away soon and
not necessarily tomorrow sir her being
gone a couple hours wouldn't raise any
red flags second how big is this county
there in that the dad can call the cops
and they'll be at the county line before
he can get across it um weren't all the
bikes including the one the dad needed
to ride for the show in this tent the
dad just stormed out of normal
motorcycle crash under a huge tent
somehow causes a big enough explosion
for Johnny and everyone else on the
outside to know something just went
wrong
also he hasn't even gotten this bike out
of the main camp yet by the time his dad
is dead he's slow especially for someone
racing to meet the love of his life and
superheroes always have dead or dying
parents cliche this is the guy the Ghost
Rider outran earlier in the movie you
mean the currently disappearing guy
right devil meets here over - crossroads
cliche the devil gif is all his servants
lessons in front of a green screen
forget about apparently Johnny's only
friend is himself
that's easy his dad just died how did
she get all the way out here without
transportation or loving parents also
Johnny writes all the way out to the
make-out tree to stand up his girlfriend
without even opening his mouth for as
much as a lie we fucked Mac slaps a guy
who could have a broken neck who's a bar
called Sam yeah that's fine how the but
you know as you literally all ran here
to check on Johnny and not one of you
has either check the bike or
communicated with anyone else on the
team who may have checked the bike any
network airing this would have
explicitly made an interview part of the
deal playing a motorcycle video game
while on tour with a motorcycle stunt
driver don't be that guy man the X Games
just happened to be on right now so that
the reporter can talk about Johnny Blaze
while they're all on the trailer luck
don't cover it JB and you got an angel
looking after you after what we've been
told as many many death-defying crashes
this is apparently the first time divine
intervention has ever been mentioned
demon shows up and makes a scary face
for no one in particular
discount Terminator biker bar Black Arts
approached causes this beer to freeze
over which should cause everything
within shouting distance to freeze over
and this freezing thing will pointlessly
come up only one more time you touch the
Carpenters or that chimp video again we
got a scrap iron this guy makes
impossible death-defying jumps enjoy
champagne glasses full of jellybeans
loves the Carpenters and apparently
everything monkey and yet this still
might only be the tenth most ridiculous
Nicolas Cage performance ever when not
turned off the TV there was a hilarious
monkey karate video play TV channels do
not magically start playing old ass
cartoons after monkey karate videos I
don't know what happened to make you
hide behind the bar but I bet whatever
it is it's a stupid idea for you to put
your goddamn head out like this I've
come for the contract of San venganza
and to kill us a loom full of people for
no reason
haha that is funny we both know you
can't harm me here I may not have power
I'll be you in this world but my rider
does why is that how it works I've never
fallen I never will then how are you
walking on the earth killing fools
does God not pay attention to stuff the
Ghost Rider your favorite creation yeah
yeah you both know who the fucking ghost
rider is I don't think you can get more
clumsy with exposition than that I'll
bury him and then I'll bury you Father
nope spoke too soon
Doni blaze was getting pumped up to 70s
tunes before star-lord was even a gleam
in his daddy's eye whoever that ends up
being big turn and that girl was thinner
than I thought
caffeine addiction for the sake of a
movie scene and then alone when
reporters will be allowed to gather in
between the locker room and the bike
jump site there's no way she heard that
and there's no way they heard her and
what the fuck is this dramatic entrance
anyway also every reporter stops doing
their job because of this hot lady
walking from aisle 18 that's Johnny
Blaze doing in an area where any peon
getting a beer can come out and yell
dead also there's no way an entrance
would be this devoid of people I'd be at
least well not sure - asshole standing
in the way eating popcorn another three
dicks checking Eva Mendes out and none
of the four dudes who feel comfortable
standing at entrances just in case you
thought there was some other hot chick
in Johnny's life that they skipped over
when he ate from supposedly 17 -
allegedly 38 actresses playing the same
character looked nothing alike but they
are both hot so maybe the movie was
banking on that to skate by seriously
what's keeping this rowdy crowd of
motorcycle stunt enthusiasts so Placid
while they wait for Johnny to come out I
would wager there isn't even a fucking
rodeo clown down there 300 feet from
field go to field go this might be the
worst interview conducted since amber
waves interviewed Dirk Diggler and they
needed a producer for this interview
this might be the most unnecessary
producers since Annie McDonald in
Groundhog Day usually jump you know we
gotta get back we're here to cover the
jump but don't need to stay for the
actual jump that's how news works these
days Johnny changes the entire jump plan
including logistics without his main
Handler and friend having a clue
Johnny remembers Roxanne from movie
angles that are not from his own
perspective so are we to believe that
the motorcycles momentum in midair is
somehow given a boost by fond memories
there's definitely something wrong here
probably because it looks finished
johnny is lucky not to knock this kid's
teeth out with his element and there's
pretty much no way he caught up to them
or knew where they were headed but not
Nicolas Cage not a real background on
the side of the freeway actually you're
in the middle of the freeway which is
why the cars are stacked up behind you
but whatever semantics thankfully no one
in this traffic jam is upset about the
traffic cam because they're all starkers
who value autographs over life and who
also apparently all recognized him from
great distances roxanne looks at her
phone and discussed as if johnny has any
idea what her cell phone number is which
we know he doesn't because she left
before telling him so she's already at
the restaurant but he hasn't even left
yet I mean this hands getting hot Bowl
should be happening at the restaurant
right what kind of an
who is this guy that is too big but why
is it a coincidence that this is
happening precisely when he's supposed
to be having dinner with his long-lost
flame is the task of killing black
hearts so pressing that his motorcycle
needs to cause property damage and small
fires as he built speed so this is how
the devil's soulcollector actually
worked wouldn't we have heard about him
by now yeah that sign is facing the
wrong way because Jonny is clearly in
Texas already actually he's in Australia
but for a movie purposes he's in Texas
also there are no large cities this
close to not Texas that a sign would be
welcoming you to Texas this soon after
leaving it how to striding past a cop
and a billboard explode the billboard
but not the cop there's an actual
tumbleweed in this scene as though this
movie has done anything to earn some
kind of Western street cred for the
filming of this scene the director asked
Nicolas Cage to do what he normally does
when the camera isn't rolling
hahahahahaha I heard Wes Bentley had to
lift 300 pounds with his neck for six
weeks to prepare for this role how's my
driving time for a hilarious joke about
bad driving cliche Blackheart and his
other minions do nothing while the Ghost
Rider is obviously sneaking up on this
guy yeah wait they left but why killing
Blackheart was so important he burned up
a whole street trying to get to it now
he decides to call it a night after
killing not black heart wait you think
I'm right way to ride a strong female
character movie give me that bag
suddenly the Ghost Rider who is under
contract to do what the devil tells him
to do has an urge to fight random crime
now with that rebel Wilson's comedy
career was launched how is it that the
fire doesn't spread to this guy's
clothes is it fake fire I'm sure I could
feel their pain if there was anything I
could actually see during this flaming
montage a blurry diarrhea so Ghost Rider
that guy the devil made by getting
Johnny to sell his soul is a good guy I
guess Johnny Blaze looked so casual in
this flaming motorcycle that it went
unnoticed by everyone in this town all
through the remainder of the night up
until morning also when the black art go
was he really afraid of the Ghost Rider
and actually left earth completely for a
night also a couple of West Bentley's
thugs
and a random mugger and that's all the
evil there is to fight in the world
tonight how does he know that whoa hey
narrator presents self as actual
character exactly halfway through the
film suppose it does somehow the
caretaker thinks that Johnny will know
what the hell it does means just by
saying it
the deal is explained 20 years after
deal was made like that regular human
mugger you killed last night it was an
obvious escape demon in between then and
now the devil had no need of a
ghostwriter even though he recruited you
about 17 years ago for some reason
forensics on the bikers and station
managers suggest the same cause of death
sulphur poison first off there's no way
you got the autopsy results at the
station manager so fast second off how
in the world do you not already have the
autopsy results at the bikers that's
what happened like days ago all right I
just not hot ass totally recognizable
reporter gets within inches of the truck
being outlined before anyone dares to
question her sulfon ever read the Old
Testament Brewster there you go hunt she
made that leap pretty damn quick even
for a movie reporter yeah make that much
fire with that rebel Wilson's comedy
career continued for some reason don't
yes it is in no way weird that you are
somehow here at the scene of the crime
just as I'm doing a live report so let
us go right into being Maddie you for
ditching me at dinner last night and
ignore the super weird timing of this
convenient occurrence that's racist I
got something how do you know that this
burned license plate is something CGI
rubber ABS now he's doing research with
house no less rather than just riding
back to the graveyard to ask Sam Elliott
for answers control this works I want to
say and how he gains control of the fire
in the first try but I think the more
simple thing is the reporter chick who
said she was done with him just randomly
showing up right as that fire is
happening but I am learning to I'm
getting control of it after one date we
have your plate and a thread from your
tires that's a crime scene no you don't
this plate came off when he was burning
through the city before he reached the
crime scene he says this about 16 times
in the scene but the fact is um yes he
did
a few even and that's if you don't count
his dad guess it's a good thing it
miraculously fits that nobody who cops
for a living is noticed or seen or heard
even one snippet is full yet forgive me
Father for
I've seen a lot honest question could
George Lucas had pulled the worst
performance out of West Bentley than
this movie did and then the Ghost Rider
walked out of the police precinct
without anyone noticing
what is that The Goonies okay random cop
decides to go with a baton rather than
the gun when it comes to escapees with
flaming skulls uh-huh
movie decides we don't need to keep up
that Texas illusion anymore let's have
Ghost Rider Drive on the highly
recognizable South Gate footbridge in
Melbourne I realize he's a skeleton but
nobody shoots at him right now fire hail
demon or no water should still
extinguish fire you know what to do he
does and why don't you go with him I
don't own three of you go at the door
came to use his supernatural ability of
pushing well of course she lives in an
apartment in perfect viewing position
for ghost writers latest stunt right she
got here already I'm okay with the ghost
guy defying the laws of physics but her
because helicopters can just recover
after being swung in the air like that
the cops just let Roxanne walked towards
a dangerous suspect in front of all the
guns Liddy found there was so evil it he
took the contract rode off any reason
why I had to wait for ghost ride her
second visit to give him this important
expositional absolutely no one from the
police is watching Johnny's apartment
after all that just happened
I need the contract why did it take
Blackhearts so long to find this
Cemetery
seems like he could have found this on
day one how come Ghost Rider knew where
to find these assholes to fight them
last night but tonight they're able to
come to his second home and beat ass on
his mentor without him coming to stop
them where's Roxanne where and how long
have you been looking for you started
this search in the morning but you
couldn't have gone to too many places
because you're wanted for murder
also we know she has a cell phone and
despite the fact that she never gave you
the number she somehow think you have it
so why didn't you try calling that so
what the hell have you been doing for 14
hours
not even close somehow black heart knows
where Johnny Blaze lives and knows that
Roxanne would be there for some reason
Donna Logie no cop notices Johnny on
this loud-ass motorcycle despite the
fact that it's dark and the rider comes
out in the presence of evil the black
heart is somehow able to surprise Johnny
your penance stare doesn't work on me
then why did you sit around doing
nothing the two times you had a chance
to kill him he may have my soul and he
doesn't have my spirit what is the
difference
any man who's got the guest to sell his
soul for the power to change
the world did it for the right reason
maybe that puts God on your side why did
the devil approach Johnny if he was
doing it for the right reason you know
to avoid things like having God on your
side holding guns why did black heart
set the meeting at that place rather
than just secretly following Johnny to
the cemetery and swooping in to get the
contract
Carter slate is still alive then what
kind of trick did he pull off so that
the devil couldn't find him can you keep
up
despite the fiery transformation of the
horse it still looks like Johnny is
holding back so that Carter can keep up
it's not like the horse is moving any
faster than a normal horse here
I guess this lizard was not innocent
truly but you literally just had one
last ride in you go don't find it all is
there a rule about two ghost riders
fighting together because the movie just
masturbated all over itself on the idea
only to instantly shut that down wait
they set a limit for the amount of
transformations a ghost rider can do and
how do you know the exact number
also you did it only so you could show
Johnny where the town was that's a waste
especially since this Ghost Rider
instinct should have been able to locate
the place on its own why didn't you just
stay fiery and help Johnny out when he
needed it water that was nowhere this
steep is suddenly this deep so that this
can happen guy who was told to stick to
the shadows rides into town out in the
open on the main road did he not
explicitly say earlier in the movie he
can sense nearby evil how does he have
to look for this asshole you change she
dies let her go first
umm now change into the ghost rider
though right right also she's at the
very least paralyzed now but I'm sure
the movie will make it seem okay in a
couple minutes
Blackheart allows this close range
exchange rather than ordering Johnny to
just drop the contract where it is
supernatural beings will now box for the
future of Earth flame ball fight also
that hurt him
but why Roxanne's boob power activated
why didn't you just do this before
flaming gargle poop pee stains part 2
Wes burnt Lee
not afraid rocks and standards took a
huge hit after that waiter gave her the
met look deal deal blaze defines the
devil who made him which makes negative
sense how is the devil able to create
writers but not control the spirit of
vengeance role credit huh
that's too early isn't it why can't
these two be together again mean love
each other they even kiss here in a
moment and he's human during the daytime
right my daddy once said if you don't
make a choice the choice makes you
actually he said you do things that
thinking you ain't make it the choice
the choice is making you but I'm sure
he'll let this bet paraphrasing go by
while he rules in his grave it said that
the West was built on legends sometimes
it said twice the guy who directed
daredevil no wonder
this is the legend of the ghost ridah
lost my train of thought here but he'll
other than introduced enough
name your price you killed him to get my
father to die
sometimes there's so much beauty in the
world
like I can't
okay trees flying on rooftops bring it
to me in San venganza and maybe I'll
spare your girl's life the rider is
coming the mystic portal away will you
be quiet let her go first very poor
choice of words